hello everyone welcome to today's live
broadcast voltammetry made easy
obtaining reliable results with nucleic
acid measurements I'm Judy O'Rourke
elaborate and I'll be your moderator for
today's event we are delighted to bring
you this educational web seminar
presented by lab roots and sponsored by
eppendorf eppendorf is a leading life
science company that develops and sells
instruments consumables and services or
liquid sample and shell handling in
laboratories worldwide for more
information please visit eppendorf com
we have a few important announcements
before you begin this webcast is
designed to be interactive and we
encourage you to ask questions during
the event you can submit questions by
typing them in the Q&A box which can be
found by clicking on the green Q&A
button at the lower left of the
presentation window we'll try to answer
as many questions as we can and will
respond in writing into questions we did
not get you today you can enlarge the
slide window by clicking on the screen
icon in the lower right hand corner of
the slide window if you have any
technical problems viewing or hearing
this presentation please click on the
support button at the top right of your
presentation window or submit your
problem through the green Q&A button
lower left I would now like to introduce
today's speaker Natasha of ice Natasha
of ice is a field application specialist
responsible for the photometer II
product portfolio within customer
support at eppendorf AG headquarters in
Hamburg Germany she joined a company in
1999 and worked on electric forretress
dispensers pcr equipment consumables as
well as several cross pneumatic project
Natasha studies biology at the
University of works for Germany for her
diploma thesis to employ a variety of
molecular biology methods investigating
genes coding for virulence factors in
the genome of pathogenic bacteria I will
now turn it over to Natasha for her
presentation Thank You Duty for your
kind introduction welcome to everyone
and thank you for joining our webinar
photo me tree made
easy my presentation will focus on the
following topics photometric basics and
nucleic acid quantification regarding
the letter I will cover the introduction
to the method factors influencing
measurements as well as tips and tricks
for troubleshooting so we start now with
photometric basics which wavelengths are
used in photometry photometry basis and
light which is the kind of
electromagnetic wave data literature
variety but light having wavelengths
from 100 to 400 nanometer is called
ultraviolet the range from 400 to 700
nanometer covers the visible light and
about 700 nanometer to an year one
millimeter we find infrared right as the
name suggests only visible light can be
seen as a color with our eyes wide light
like the Sun contains all wavelengths
including ultraviolet visible and
infrared light such white light may be
split into narrow band of wavelengths
using tools like a filter or prison this
results in the so-called monochromatic
light photometric measurement for most
biochemical methods are applied at a
wavelength from approximately 200 up to
nine hundred nanometer different
materials absorb light at specific
wavelengths this can be shown in a
photometric scan across a large
wavelength range and here you see an
example of the dye brilliant blue
spectrophotometry is a scientific method
which phases on the absorption of light
by substance and uses the physical laws
of light absorption for the calculation
of the concentration of the substance
therefore the absorbance intensity at
one specific wavelength the peak
wavelength is used
additionally measurements at further
wavelength can be applied to check the
purity of the sample most important part
of a photometer are a light source a
place for positioning the sampler to be
studied and the detector for determining
the light intensity which is transmitted
by the samples an additional element
which is not included on the slide as a
part a belief lit white light into a
monochromatic light in a photometer
incident light with an intensity i0
passes through a sample the light which
is not absorbed by the sample is
transmitted and measured by the detector
the intensity of transmitted light is
termed I the ratio of I to i0 gives the
transmittance which is often expressed
as a percentage resulting in the
percentage transmittance the software of
the photometer can convert the amount of
light that is transmitted into the
amount of light that was absorbed by the
solution the formula which is used for
this calculation is that the absorbance
corresponds to the negative tech etic
logarithm of the transmittance in a
photometer the detector determined the
absorbance by processing the information
of incident light intensity and measured
transmitted light intensity absorbance
which is measured depends on three
parameters C stands for the cell
concentration and Al for the optical
path length which is defined by the cue
that used and describes the distance
travelled by the light epsilon is the
molar extinction coefficient which is
the physical constant of a molecule
used to define its ability to absorb
light of a specific wavelength I will
explain more about this coefficient
leaders the Lambert bear law describes
these correlations and represents there
by the basis for photometry it is a
combination of the Lambert's law which
states that the absorbance of a sample
is directly proportional to the distance
travelled by the light and the beers law
which says that absorbance is
proportional to the concentration of the
sample many photo meters inclusive the
program's bathing on the reformed
Lambert beer law which enable the direct
calculation of the concentration of
specific sample types why measure
absorbance instead of transmittance the
aim of spectrophotometry and biochemical
applications is to determine the
concentration of substances so why do we
prefer to express the limit bello using
absorbance as a measure rather than
percentage transmittance on the slide
you see a series of samples each of them
absorbs fifty percent of the incoming
light so the amount of the original
radiation passed by the first sample is
fifty percent by the second sample is
twenty-five percent and by the third
sample is 12.5 percent by plotting the
transmittance as well as the absorbance
we see that transmission leads to an
exponential decaying curve whereas the
absorbance values which base on a
logarithmic formula result in a linear
graph we have seen that the amount of
light diminished exponentially as it
traveled through the material therefore
transmittance is obviously difficult for
determination of sample concentration
since the absorbance
a sample is defined by a logarithmic
formula it is directly proportional to
the concentration of the absorbing
material there's linearly relationship
enables an easy and convenient
quantification of samples in order to
get a feeling for the meaning of
absorbance units I put common
photometric values with corresponding
percentage transmittance rates together
on the slide you see that view to the
logarithmic formula Zera absorbance
originates from a transmittance rate of
one hundred percent an absorbance of one
is equal to ten ten percent light
transmittance and an absorbance of two
corresponds to one percent transmission
much higher absorbance values will not
be suitable since any further increase
in concentration will reflect only
slight changes in absorbance and the
amount of light which reaches the
detector will be too low so this leads
to the question which absorbance range
is reasonable in photometry we have
absorbed the linear dependency between
absorbance and concentration but this
linearity is limited by chemical and
instrumental sectors the lambeth power
law is not valid for high concentrated
samples due to strong molecular
interactions and limitations are given
by stray light effect of the photometer
used dre light can be caused by scatter
or reflection of light inside the device
that reaches the detector and it will
severally impact high adsorbents
measurements in the graphic the
influence of different amounts of stray
light is shown by a plot of measured
absorbance versus real absorbance only
when no stray light is available total
linearity can be achieved the curves of
measured absorbance will start
flattening the earlier the higher the
stray light
conant of a photometer which means that
concentration of high absorbing samples
will be underestimated according to this
example readings up to 1 are perfectly
linear devices with the lowest rated
rate will also give reliable values up
to 2 absorbance unit besides deviations
when measuring high absorbance the
Lambert BL or is also limited when very
low concentrated samples are used due to
background noise coming from electronic
electronic components of the photometer
and the environment the figure on the
right side illustrates that an
absorbance higher than Oh point one can
be easily distinguished from the noise
whereas this becomes more difficult with
lower central concentrations it has to
be considered that the percentage of the
error increases with low concentrations
and yes and you have to decide by
yourself which error is acceptable for
your application if you want to be on
the safe side your values should lie
between 0 point 1 and 1 absorbance unit
besides the photometer a cuvette which
contains the sample solution is required
for photometric measurement each key
that includes optical paths through
which the light can pass these optical
paths have to be transparent for the
wavelengths used for photometric
measurements for applications employing
UV light a cuvette from central plastic
or glass is not suitable instead a qubit
made from UV transparent material like
quartz glass or specific plastic has to
be used each photometer has a specific
height at which the light beam will pass
the sample typical heights are 8.5 10 or
15 millimeter take care that the cuvette
and the photometer are comfortable
regarding the height of the light path
respectively
I'd beam another important and parameter
is the path length of the culet which is
defined by the travelling distance of
light to the simple the standard measure
for path length is 10 millimeter but
several other options like 12 or five
millimeters are available to small path
lengths are typically used for micro
volume measurements using high
concentrated samples all substances is
key will not absorb sunlight therefore
we have to consider that light is also
absorbed by the cuvette and the central
solvent is we want to determine the
concentration of a substance in order to
obtain the absorbance of the sample only
you have to subtract the absorbance of
the cuvette and of the solvent so a
blank measurement at the same wavelength
and using the same human and solvent as
for the sample enables us to set the
photometer 20 prior to sample
measurement before we start with the
next chapter I would like to ask you
know to participate in our first poll
which you will see on the screen now
so you see the result now we see that
fifty-eight percent already performed
create the quantification and for 12.5
percent it is planned
I would like to go on with the next part
nucleic acid quantifications by
introducing the method first why measure
nucleic acids nucleic acids are isolated
in order to have them available for a
high variety of downstream applications
reactions that use nucleic acids often
require particular amounts and high
quality for optimum performance
therefore it is crucial to evaluate the
concentration as well as the purity
after isolation especially the presence
of inhibiting contaminants which may be
attributed to poor sample preparation
which are associated with the difficult
sense of metrics like blood or soil can
lead to visible problems extra products
may be generated during pcr analyzers
activity of restriction and modifying
enzymes can reduce transfection shows
low efficiency or shaw dread length
during sequencing candle cure UV
spectrophotometry represents an easy
method to perform quantification and
quality control of DNA and RNA nucleic
acids show an absorbance peak at 216
nanometer which allows for simple
estimation of the concentration after
absorbance measurement the software of
the photometer directly calculates the
concentration of the sample bathing on
the Lambert bear law therefore the
sample specific sector which is 15
micrograms per milliliter for deer a
double-stranded DNA is used in this
example on this slide you find some more
information on the molar extinction
coefficient epsilon of the Lambert Bell
or it is a sample specific value valid
for a specific wavelength and the
standard cubed path length of 10
millimeter the corresponding values for
this
the plague asa types are given in the
first column of the table for
calculation of the concentration the
lambeth bear law has to be reformed
using the risk Procol value of epsilon 1
is divided by absolut and this stands
for the commonly used standard factors
50 40 or 33 microgram per milliliter for
double-stranded DNA RNA and singers
stranded DNA respectively the underlying
statement is that an absorbent of 1
corresponds to a concentration of 50
micrograms per milliliter
double-stranded DNA in a 10 millimeter
cubed the resulting detection range for
an optimal absorbance between 0 point 1
and 1 absorbance units is listed in the
right column of the table a number of
other substances which also absorb light
at 260 nanometer can interfere with DNA
or RNA values and lead to an
artificially increased result to
compensate for this purity ratios and
background can have been developed to
help eliminate false readings potential
contaminants like proteins carbohydrates
souls and organic solvents show hi
absorbance at 230 and 280 nanometer this
wavelengths are used to calculate the
purity ratios a to 162 a 280 and a 262 a
200 turkey for determining the
background a measurement at 320 or 340
nanometer is typical on this slide some
more information and most important
contaminants is given proteins are a
probable contaminant after isolation of
nucleic acids they have an absorbance
peak at 218 animate
and additionally absorbance at 230
nanometer is very high for potent high
absorbance values at 230 nanometer can
also indicate the presence of other
impurities like carbohydrates Cal tropic
souls and organic solvents in advance I
would like to say that different values
are found in the literature regarding
pure nucleic acid samples and the
corresponding purity ratios one
explanation is that results are
published which bases on different
buffers used as a solvent and the pH
value of the buffer has an influence on
duration references which are the basis
for the ratios I mentioned are on the
respective slides the most common purity
check for DNA and RNA is the 262 208
Eurasian since any protein contamination
will have a maximum absorbance at 280
nanometer measurements are taken at both
260 and 280 nanometer and compared to
give eration for DNA the result needs to
be 1.8 to 1.9 to indicate a good level
of purity in the sample an hour and a
sample is considered pure for ratio of
one point 92 to due to its higher ratio
of red seal as compared to two min which
is a component and DNA results lower
than these indicate impurities from
proteins as well as from aromatic
compounds like phenol which shows an
absorbent speak at 270 nanometers a
blank solution which is not appropriate
can lead to an increased ratio and the
value of 24 DNA may be the result of
high amounts of ribosomal RNA in the
sample
a number of substances absorb at 230
nanometer as this is the region of
absorbance of peptide bond aromatic side
chains carbohydrates cat hapax oats and
organic solvents values between 32 and
2.5 for the 260 230 ratio are typical
for a pure sample a lower ratio can
result from carbohydrate carryover for
example for sample matrixes like plants
but also from traces of reagents used
during nucleic acid extraction like
phenyl or gtc which stands for the cat
tropics old bernadine isothiocyanate an
untreatable blind solution can either
lead to a low ratio as well as to a very
high to 106 C 2 230 value for background
correction absorbance is measured at a
point on the spectrum which is unrelated
to the sample absorbance this reading
can be subtracted from the peak values
for UV spectrophotometry of nucleic
acids typical background wavelength at
to a 320 or 340 nanometer I used since
nucleic acids the not absorbed in this
range so the value should be closed 20
background may be due to light scatter
caused by contaminant particles air
bubbles or by a precipitate in the
sample additionally dirty or damaged
qubits as well as not enough sample
solution inside can cause absorbance at
320 nanometer measuring and correcting
for this reading can therefore be used
to remove any interference from
particles and other reasons of light
scatter
a mixture of different nucleic acid
types like DNA and RNA cannot be
distinguished in absorbance measurements
since they show the same peak at 260
nanometer it can be crucial when for
example plasmid DNA is isolated from
bacteria without rnase digestion since
ninety percent of the purified nucleic
acids our RNA the resulting calculated
DNA concentration based on absorbance
measurement will lead to wrong results
due to massive overestimation since our
nation's higher absorbance than DNA the
real amount of DNA will be even lower
than indicated taking this together
there is a high risk to negatively
affect follow-up applications as
alternative photometric method which
enables the differentiation between
different nucleic acid types is
quantification by fluorescence
measurements here in a so-called
fluorometer measures the fluorescence
intensity of a dye that barnes to a
nucleic acid fluorescence dyes can react
very specifically so the dye pico green
for example only bind to double-stranded
DNA and the pump binding to the DNA the
fluorescence of pico green increases
more than 1000 fold which leads to the
high sensitivity of the method
incorporated diet absorb light of their
specific excitation wavelengths and will
afterwards the mid light of a lower
emission wavelength the intensity of the
emitted light is compared to standard
measurements and the concentration of an
unknown sample is calculated accordingly
compare the methods we see that both
have their advantages and disadvantages
so the decision which one of the most
sweet abul will depend on the sample and
the educational requirements the
detection limit for fluorescence
measurements is quite low so it enables
the quantification of high diluted
samples additionally the method is very
specific regarding the target molecule
and therefore three double for mixed
sample types information on Santa purity
and possible interfering substances are
only available with absorbance
measurement for sensitive downstream
applications it may be useful to perform
both types of measurements in order to
achieve a very accurate quantification
in combination with information on the
quality of the sample so before we come
to the next part you will shortly see in
the next poll of for all of you who
already do nucleic acid quantification
by photometry
so you will see in a few seconds value
is see now the results um yes sixty-four
percent approximately do UV absorbance
measurements not that much approximately
seven percent fluorescence measurement
and almost twenty-nine percent perform
already both methods thank you for
participation so the next part is about
nucleic acid quantification in the
factors and Francine measurements which
I will present on the following slides
another relevant parameter is the path
length of the cuvette and its influence
on measurement stand of chibok path
length is 10 millimeter but when using a
high concentrated solution readings may
be too high to be detected correctly by
the photometer in order to lower the
absorbance the sample can be either
diluted orator nativ Leah cubed with the
smaller path length can be choosen in
the table you see the effect when
reducing the path length on the maximum
detectable double-stranded DNA
concentration for an absorbance of one's
turbidity which results from particles
like microbial growth or magnetic beads
will lead to an overall higher absorbent
since these solids absorb across the
whole measuring range the same effect
comes from a dirty cuvette or qubit
shaft air bubbles or meniscus in the
height of the light beam when the liquid
level inside the qubit is too low a
clown values pretend a higher
concentration of the sample and falsify
purity ratios additionally
like microbial growth can negatively
affect down to three reactions besides
solid contaminants different solubles
may be found in sample solutions to
sources are the sample matrix with
proteins and main contaminant but there
are also carbohydrates from plant
material or Yuma cases from soil samples
in addition traces of reagents used
during the isolation of nucleic acids
are found typical examples are phenyl or
thoughts like gtc proteins as well as
organic solvents and thoughts have a
strong decreasing effect on the 260 230
racial furthermore proteins lead to a
reduction of the ratio 260 280 the
purity ratios are used as an indicator
in order to decide if the isolated
nucleic acids are pure enough to be used
in downstream applications especially
organic solvents and high salt
concentrations can show inhibitory
effects with lower the efficiency of
genotyping experiment or the transection
of sensitive cells this light
demonstrate that mixing the sample
carefully for example after resuspension
and dilution steps is very important in
order to receive reliable results for
the experiment shown here ten
microliters of DNA solution have been
added to 90 microliter buffer it is
clear that no mixing result in a
heterogeneous solution but even after
three times to spending with the tip the
sample solution is not homogeneous
whereas war texting is very effective
indicators for this effect are
fluctuating values when measuring the
sample multiple times
I have mentioned before that blank
measurements are necessary to subtract
the absorbance from Cuba and solvent
from Santa measurement therefore it is
important to use exactly the same
solvent for blank as well as for the
sample the images on this slide show
what happened to the DNA spectrum when
different solvents for blank and sample
have been used in the first example
Walter was taken as a blank solution and
tris buffer lost the sample solvent in
the second example the solutions were
used vice versa we see a high impact on
the spectra which are far away from a
normal DNA absorbance spectrum as well
as on the purity ratio 260 230 in the
first example additionally the racial
260 280 is slightly increased whereas
the second example shows in sample
concentration which will be more than
twice as high as the real solution from
this result you see that it is extremely
important to use the same solution for
blank as for sample solvent now we come
to the top pole and it would be great if
you can give us an your answer about how
often you face problems in nucleic acid
quantification
so we see the result of this third pole
now so just five percent of you have
never faced any problems whereas
approximately half of you see them
Raleigh and almost forty four percent
face frequently problems so I hope we
can have a little bit with this webinar
would like to come to the last part of
my talk which is about tips and tricks
for troubleshooting when setting up a
photometric experiment it is recommended
to use the calibrated pipette with
corresponding tips in order to endure
that delusions are prepared correctly
avoid delusions higher than 1 to 50
since they result in a higher error
probability for a blank example the same
solvent has to be used suitable is a
slightly alkaline buffer like trees
since also the pH value can affect
sample readings after dilution carefully
mix the sample if required in
combination with a short centrifugation
step it is also advantageous to have all
solutions at room temperature if
possible a cuvette which is used for
photometric measurements has to be clean
and intact generally this is given for
disposable qubits but it is important to
clean quad qubits carefully and control
them on a regular basis for scratches
for measuring nucleic acids Yuri
transparencies of course a prerequisite
but also make sure that the light path
page corresponds with the light beam
hate of the photometer for wavelengths
are important for the evaluation of
nucleic acids these are 230 260 280 +
320 nanometers nevertheless a complete
scan of this wavelength range can
provide additional information regarding
potential errors when programming the
photometer have a look on the following
settings the path length of the queue
that you take the unit of your result
and the right sector according to your
nucleic acid sample forever
creation of the quality both purity
ratios as well as background absorbance
are informative present or that the
minimum volume required for the cubit
type is used it is advisable to take
always some microliter in excess in
order to avoid in a meniscus affect not
only large air bubbles like the ones
shown on the picture here also smaller
ones which are not visible at first
glance can influence the reading
therefore check always blank as well as
sample solution for air bubbles prior to
measurement after reading the samples it
is important to evaluate all results
first and most important point is
whether absorbance values are within the
linear range of the photometer then look
for background at 320 nanometer low
values up to approximately 0 point 0 3
may be corrected that means they are
subtracted from all other results if the
absorbance is higher it is advisable to
look for the cause of background
patrolman's if these two parameters are
fine you can have a look on the purity
ratios and optionally the scan for
evaluating their quality however please
be aware that the purity ratios from
literature idea ones and there are
diverse samples like body fluids or soil
samples which will never meet these
values so the ratios are helpful for
determining the quality but they will
not replace your own rating on sample
quality resulting from your experience
so you have to define your own
acceptable range depending on sample
metrics and requirements of your
applications as you seen in
is example the ratio 262 230 is slightly
lower than two point O although this is
not a perfect value these samples
perform well and downstream applications
they are useful anyway hi absorbance
values result and stray light effect on
the photometer in order to ensure that
measurements are in the linear range
samples can be either diluted or
accurate with a shorter path length can
be choosen no readings are influenced by
background noise for achieving better
accuracy it is recommended to
concentrate the sample or to use a lower
dilution the cubic path length can be
increased when the short length has been
taken before if only low amounts of low
concentrated samples are available
evaluation by fluorescence can be an
alternative hi background can be caused
by particles in the sample but a dirty
qubit air bubbles or a low sample volume
can lead to the same effect for
relatively low readings you can just
activate the background correction in
order to correct your data for higher
background you should have a closer look
on the reason often the simple
centrifugation step removing air bubbles
or rhesus Panjal of sample precipitates
is sufficient but sometimes further
purification of the sample is necessary
in order to avoid an influence on
downstream applications if a lower to
160 to 200 80 ratio is present in most
cases also 262 230 values are strongly
reduced this effect is typically seen
for contaminations with proteins as well
as aromatic compounds like phenol the
rain
sure 262 280 increases when an
unreadable blank solution is used and
DNA is contaminated with RNA only a lil
262 230 value without any effect on 262
208 Eurasia isn't indicative for
contaminations by carbohydrates organic
solvents and salts especially
guanidinium source if water is used as
blank and the sample of soft and buffer
we see a similar effect on the other
hand the ratio will increase
dramatically where the blank consists of
buffer whereas the sample basis and
water sometimes the senior measurement
will not reveal any problems and
everything is fine at first sight but
when you measure the sample again you
see different results such fluctuating
values can be induced by particles and
air bubbles as well as by a drift of the
pH value however the most important
reason is unsur ficient mixing after
reason spending or dilution steps it is
advisable to mix samples very carefully
for example by war texting
now the last slide of my presentation
how can you optimize your photo metric
measurements the first point is to
choose a method for nucleic acid
isolation which is adapted to your
sample matrix and ritual result in pure
nucleic acids then think on a careful
set up regarding clean and calibrated
equipment using a suitable buffer and
careful mixing take care that the
equipment is readable for you re
measurement and program the parameters
of the photometer correctly prior to
measurement check for the minimum volume
as well as for air bubbles last but not
least evaluate your data regarding
linear measuring range background purity
ratios and if available the spectrum so
thank you very much for your attention
we have now the look on your questions
and we'll start to answer them in the
following session questions we cannot
cover today will be answered later via
email in the meantime are you may have a
look on the last Paul where you can rate
the content of this webinar thank you in
advance for your feedback
thank you for that informative
presentation before we get started on
the question and answer session I'd like
to remind our audience how to submit
questions you can submit questions by
typing them in the Q&A box which can be
found by clicking on the green Q&A
button at the lower left of the
presentation window we'll try to answer
as many questions as we can and our
first question is can a sample with a
lower concentrations affected to 62 230
ratio
yes the low concentration low
concentrated samples will affect of
course the accuracy of the reading and
since all readings the reading at 260
nanometer as well as the reading at 230
nanometer is affected also the ratio 262
230 will be influenced and cone can show
higher or lower results can you measure
absorbance be affected by the use of
cold samples yes code samples can also
affect the measure of absorbance
especially if the code samples will then
warm up in the device because
temperature differences can be result in
the fluctuated readings too great what
did you the reasons for negative values
in a result
um negative results can occur when you
mix a blank and sample solution or if
you use an old suitable blank solution
so for example and the sense of a soft
in water and the blank is a buffer which
absorbs highly in the UV range
additionally negative values can be
caused by a dirty cuvette or cubed shaft
or as a result from air bubbles or
meniscus is be required to perform a
complete wavelength stand for
quantification of nucleic acids notice
is not required but it can be sometimes
helpful in principle you need for the
evaluation of nucleic acids just
measurements at the wavelengths I have
presented before nevertheless spectrum
in the UV UV range may be beneficial for
affiliation if you face any problems in
which case do I have to use cuvettes
with shorter path length than the
standard 1 centimeter if you if you use
a 1 centimeter cubed and your sample
results in absorbance readings which are
above the linear measuring range then
you have two options you can either
dilute the sample or you cannot chew you
can choose the cubit with the shorter
path length especially micro volume
systems like the nanodrop or the app and
of micro cuit of sweet able for
measuring small volumes of very high
concentrated solutions on the other hand
few Reds with one centimeter path length
I required if you want to detect lower
concentrations accurately well their
gain influence of degraded DNA or RNA on
the results to yes there will be an
influence since degraded nucleic acids
will be detected by absorbance
measurements tool and this will lead to
an overestimation of the concentrate
of the intact DNA or RNA or nucleic
acids and nucleotides contribute to an
absorbent reading at 260 nanometer can I
determine the incorporation rate of
fluorescence diet into nucleic acids yes
it is possible to determine the
incorporation rate therefore you do
absorbance measurements at different
wavelengths the concentration of the
nucleic acid is detected as usual at 260
nanometer and additionally wavelength is
used which is specific for the
incorporated die for example 550
nanometer for the die size 3 the
correlation of these values results then
early incorporation rate in which way
can I fell to me to be checked yes
speaking for the eppendorf photometer
and spectrophotometer there are UV this
reference photo sets available and these
can be used for the calibration of the
devices that means that accuracy and
precision are verified similar fit
effects are also used by our service can
I use the same type ask you gets booked
for fluorescence measurements as for
absorbance measurements the type of
cubed which can be used for fluorescence
depends on the positioning of the
optical part in the device in many flow
meters the detector is placed at right
angle to the light source so then you
have to choose the cuvette with optical
windows on three or four sides up there
also devices like the eppendorf bio
spectrometer for assistance with light
source and detector on our websites and
in this case or standard to vets made
from acrylic glass polystyrene or you
we transparent plastic or glass can be
used important is that you check that
the autofluorescence of the cubit is not
too high okay and I looks like we might
have time for one last question whether
the results of a single game of
photometer are able to represent the
entire sample mean absorbance um we will
answer this question they do this is a
little bit too complicated to explain
now so we will also this in an email
okay thank you so much I'd like to thank
our sponsor eppendorf for making today's
educational webcast possible today's
webcast will be available for on-demand
viewing through October sixteenth 2015
you'll receive an email from lab boots
alerting you when this webcast will be
available for replay we invite you to
for that announcement to your colleagues
who may have missed today's live event
okay next time bye